in this little village of khadir in
Sudan's North Darfur State zainab
Muhammad is rebuilding her life a former
Refugee who fled to Chad during the
early years of the Darfur War she says
tough conditions in the camps across the
border made her and her family decide to
return to the region
there was little food being given there
there were water shortages so we came
back here we can Farm and Feed ourselves
and sell what remains to get an income
we're now fixing the house so we don't
go back to the camps it's not much but
sustainable zainab and her family are
some of more than 100 000 refugees
who've returned from Chad in the past
five years more than 2 million people
were displaced by the war in Darfur
which started in 2003 hundreds of
thousands of those crossed the border
into neighboring Chad while some people
have returned to their Villages or built
new ones settling in can be difficult
900 000 people were displaced by
violence between communities last year
alone most had previously been displaced
by the war and in other areas just
economic conditions have forced people
back into displacement camps
not all those who return settle
permanently the reminders of the war are
still visible in Tina homes that have
been bombarded by government forces
chasing Rebel Fighters remain untouched
in the last 20 years
a few miles away is the border crossing
that refugees use to flee from here
zainab dugong uses it daily to move from
the camps to Tina and back
my son goes to school while I work to
earn some money to feed my family I come
every morning and return to the camping
Chad at the end of every day but my old
home has been destroyed and I can't
rebuild it so I can't return and settle
here the un's refugee agency says
long-term responses is necessary for
those who've returned and for those
still in camps to come back home
we have to look to new approaches that
can try to address a more complex series
of durable Solutions whereby we help to
increase resilience create livelihoods
rebuild social services and encourage
social cohesion peaceful coexistence
zainab says she knows her life won't be
like it to us before the war but she
says as long as there is no fighting
she'll stay in this Village and try to
build a future for her and her family
Hebrew Morgan Al Jazeera Tina Northstar
foreign